♫ ♫
>> Chris: SERIOUS MEDIA SAYS A
U.S. ATTACK ON TROOPS BACKING
THE ASSAD REGIME IS A NEW EFFORT
TO SUPPORT TERRORISM.
THE PENTAGON’S AS AMERICAN
TROOPS WERE JUST DEFENDING
THEMSELVES.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHY AND SOME OF THE
IMAGES IN HER REPORT MAY BE
DISTURBING.
>> FOR MORE THAN TWO YEARS, THE
RUSSIANS HAVE PROTECTED THE
REGIME OF SYRIAN
PRESIDENT BASHAR AL-ASSAD EVEN
AMIDST MOUNTING EVIDENCE LIKE
THIS VIDEO RELEASED BY A SYRIAN
AID GROUP TODAY THAT THE SYRIAN
GOVERNMENT CONTINUES TO BOMB ITS
OWN PEOPLE.
POUNDING CIVILIANS IN THE SUBURB
OUTSIDE DAMASCUS.
NOW THERE IS A RISING CONCERN
FOLLOWING THE DEFEAT OF ISIS
THAT THE SYRIAN CIVIL WAR IS
TURNING INTO A PROXY FIGHT
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND RUSSIA
PUTTING THE LIVES OF 2,000